[Musique]
je suis Stéphane Favier je suis le
directeur du Centre rte de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
[Musique]
alors ici vous êtes sur un site depuis
lequel nous pilotons nous contrôlons
nous assurons l'alimentation électrique
de la région Île-de-France et de la
région Normandie depuis un peu plus d'un
an maintenant ici sur ce site RTE
développe une activité de surveillance
des systèmes d'information de RTE une
activité de cybersécurité une activité
de pilotage des réseaux télécom de RTE
cette composante est très importante
pour RTE parce que peu elle permet de
sécuriser tous nos systèmes
d'information et tous nos systèmes de
contrôle du réseau électrique
[Musique]
les défis de demain c'est d'augmenter et
de monter fortement en puissance sur
l'activité de pilotage du système
industriel de RTE de surveillance cyber
de surveillance Télécom l'intelligence
artificielle est une vraie opportunité
dans les activités que l'on mène depuis
un centre comme celui-ci pourquoi parce
qu'en fait de plus en plus de paramètres
de l'alimentation électrique du réseau
vont varier on a de la production
éolienne on a de la production solaire
qui vont arriver qui dépendent
évidemment des conditions
météorologiques et qui du coup doivent
être intégrés au travers d'outils d'aide
à la décision pour les dispatcheurs pour
les opérateurs qui gèrent le réseau
électrique depuis ce centre
[Musique]